parte de sí efe de uno es igual a tres
escribe una expresión para fx que
involucre una integral así que dice que
involucre una integral y estoy seguro
que debe de involucrar también a la
primera derivada de x y más cuando nos
han dado tanta información acerca de f
prima por ejemplo su gráfica su área
debajo o por encima de la curva de
diferentes integrales etcétera y ya por
último nos piden que encontremos a efe
de 4 y a efe de menos 2 entonces vamos a
pensar cómo podemos conectar esto como
podemos conectar a la primera derivada
de x con una integral y bueno para eso
piensa que va a pasar si tomamos la
integral de am avn de no sé se me ocurre
pensar en f prima de x
esto de x qué es esto que obtengo de
tomarme esta integral bueno pues esto va
a ser la anti derivada de este prima de
x lo cual es fx fx está evaluada en am y
b y después nos tomamos la diferencia es
decir esto va a ser lo mismo que
efe db
- efe de a estás de acuerdo lo único que
hice fue aplicar el teorema fundamental
del cálculo ok pero esto es muy
interesante porque qué tal si en lugar
de ver pongo aquí a x y bueno si ponemos
a x en uno de nuestros límites de
integración entonces también vamos a
tener que cambiar la variable de
integración déjame hacerlo esto me va a
quedar de la siguiente manera qué pasa
si me tomo la integral de a la x de f
prima y vamos a cambiar la variable de
integración así que voy a poner de f
prima de un d
a que va a ser igual esto bueno pues si
seguimos la misma lógica esto va a ser
lo mismo que f de x menos
efe de a siguiendo la misma lógica la
anti derivada evaluada en x el límite
superior menos la andi derivada evaluada
en el límite inferior perfecto pero
queremos resolver para ftx entonces si
sumamos f
de ambos lados voy a obtener que fx va a
ser igual a la integral de aa x de f
prima de 1 y bueno recuerda que estoy
cambiando las variables para no
confundirnos y poder poner a x como el
límite superior de esta integral podría
usar cualquier variable a efe prima de
uno de uno
más
fede a más efe am y esta es la forma
general para encontrar a fx ahora fíjate
que también nos dan otro dato por aquí
esto también es parte de la información
de este inciso f 1 es igual a 3
así que qué te parece si elegimos que
amp tomen el valor de 1 entonces aquí lo
que daría 1 y aquí me quedaría 1 y
entonces ftx fx se va a ver como la
integral de 1 porque ahora a vale 1 de 1
x de efe prima de uno de uno de uno más
efe de uno pero sabemos cuánto vale f de
1 f1 es igual a 3 es lo que nos dan
entonces esto + 3 y ya con esto está de
lujo porque tenemos la primera parte de
este inciso
esta es la respuesta de la primera parte
que dice escribe una expresión para fx
que involucre una integral muy bien
ahora ya que tenemos esta integral que
te parece si buscamos el valor de f de 4
y bueno ft 4 va a ser igual si
sustituimos en esta fórmula a x x 4
me quedaría la integral de 1 a 4 de f
prima de un gesto de 1
+ 3 no olvidemos más de 3 entonces
cuánto va a ser la integral de 14 de f
prima dvd 1 para eso vamos a regresar a
la gráfica que teníamos acá arriba hasta
arriba esta de aquí porque si pensamos
en la integral de 1 a 4 de esta función
que tengo aquí observamos que es el área
de esta sección que está por encima de
la curva es toda esta área que tengo
aquí pero ojo esto nos da una región con
área negativa porque si sólo te tomas la
integral estás pensando en el área por
encima del eje
y entre los límites de la integral en
este caso tenemos algo por debajo del
eje x por abajo del eje horizontal por
eso en este caso tenemos un área
negativa y de hecho no nos daba el
problema recuerdas
dice la región encerrada en el intervalo
1 a 4 es de 12 entonces esta área es de
12 pero nos vamos a tomar el área
negativa lo cual serán menos 12 ahora si
podemos regresar al problema y sustituir
esa información entonces todo esto de
aquí todo esto es menos 12 y entonces me
va a quedar menos 12 3 lo cual es 9
negativo menos 9
perfecto y ya con eso tengo a efe de 4
ahora vamos a pensar cuánto vale
efe
- 2
y bueno si sustituimos a x por menos 2
en esta expresión que tengo aquí me va a
quedar lo mismo que la integral de uno a
menos dos de f1 de f prima de un d
y a esto habrá que sumarle 3 pero no
sientes que algo extraño por aquí bueno
es que el límite superior es menor al
límite inferior así que podemos escribir
esto de la siguiente manera podemos
poner un signo menos antes de la
integral y voltear los límites de
integración entonces me quedaría la
integral negativa desde menos 2 hasta 1
de f prima de 1
de 13 y ahora vamos a preguntarnos por
cuál es la integral de menos 2 a 1
efe prima de uno de uno y eso también
nos lo dan está justo acá arriba en la
gráfica si observas de menos dos a uno
tenemos en esta región esta región y el
área de esta región nos dicen que es lo
mismo que 9 pero de nuevo estamos por
debajo del eje horizontal entonces
podemos decir que la integral que
queremos evaluar va a ser de menos 9 ojo
el área es de 9 pero como la curva está
por debajo del eje horizontal
entonces la integral tomará el valor de
menos 9 y ahora sí podemos sustituir eso
mismo acaba entonces esta integral de
aquí toman el valor de menos 9 y
entonces esto me va a quedar como menos
-9
+ 3 lo cual es lo mismo que 93 es 2 y ya
con esto hemos acabado